another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do at the foundation no using  scps to create tentacle monsters even if  dr palmer asks nicely there are a vast  number of anomalous technologies that  would allow aboard dr bright to try his  hand at playing god with some genetic  engineering including in theory creating  tentacle monsters this may seem innocent  enough but due to certain japanese  censorship laws tentacle monsters have  taken on a whole new meaning especially  to one of dr bright's colleagues dr  palmer who will happily tell you about  her favorite anime my husband is a  tentacle monster in another world  needless to say the foundation would  prefer that their employees do this kind  of thing at home